[Music]
thank you so much for being here
thank you for having you look absolutely
gorgeous nice to have you on the show I
do thank you let's talk about that um I
I don't mean to make you self-conscious
but I noticed when I was talking to you
in in the dressing room that you one of
your eyes is a different color than the
other eye which is a condition what is
it known as it's much less attractive
when you give it its name it's called
heterochromia it's a disease it's a
disease okay I'm so glad I started the
interview with it
what doesn't it's not a disease it's
it's David Bowie how slowly that's how
you said I noticed a bow he beat Bowie
David Bowie has it in the in the United
Kingdom you say bow II bowing David
Bowie yeah and if you don't like thee no
I don't at all no he to us he's David
Bowie
oh yeah David Bowie has it okay yes I
know I when I've interviewed him I've
noticed it's quite striking I think it's
more striking in him yeah um one time it
took my boyfriend bit one boyfriend one
time one boyfriend who soon wasn't my
boyfriend it took nine months to notice
he I understand no way he's like nine
nine months he was with you and and you
did you got insulted that he he didn't
look into your eyes and notice that yeah
he was like do you have different
colored eyes I was like what are you
joking what have you been looking at
nine months in so yeah I have
heterochromia and but that's it it's you
said it's a disease but it really isn't
you okay no it's not yeah oh good cool
thank you yes she was joking
that's a nice joke she's fine um
you